después de que su ingreso hospitalario
el miércoles desatará preocupación
mundial la salud del Papa Francisco
Mejora y retomó su trabajo desde el
hospital según Un responsable del
Vaticano el pontífice fue hospitalizado
por una infección respiratoria pero aún
no está claro cuando será dado de alta y
si estará lo suficientemente bien como
para participar en la ajetreada semana
de ceremonias previas Al domingo de
resurrección
estamos en la víspera de lo que es la
semana más ocupada en el Vaticano en
términos de sus liturgias públicas entre
ahora y el próximo domingo de pascua el
papa Está programado para presidir al
menos siete ceremonias públicas es una
gran incógnita si el Papa Francisco
tendrá o no la energía para hacerlo y si
saldrá o no del hospital
a principios de marzo el pontífice
argentino cumplió una década al frente
de la Iglesia Católica pero no es la
primera vez que se teme por su salud
desde hace un año utiliza una silla de
ruedas y en el verano pasado admitió que
tenía que bajar el ritmo
considerado por muchos como un líder
compasivo y reformador su mala salud
tiene conmocionado a los fieles
[Música]
desgraciadamente he oído las noticias
sobre el papa y lo siento porque es una
persona por la que siente un gran
respeto sobre todo por sus opiniones me
parece una persona racional
desgraciadamente es una de las pocas
personas racionales que quiere enviar un
mensaje de paz que empuja por la paz
Espero que se recupere lo antes posible
y pueda reanudar la celebraciones
a primera hora del jueves el papa
publicó un tweet Agradeciendo a las
personas sus mensajes y oraciones a
pesar de varios problemas de salud a lo
largo de los años anteriormente ha dicho
que la renuncia no está en su agenda y
que las renuncias papales como la de su
predecesor Benedicto 16 no deberían ser
la